I grew up in a very economically
depressed place and I was really struck
at a young age by the fact that
everybody just was sort of in survival
mode one has to really believe in the
films once making like in my heart has
to be in it
this is our lives this is what we spend
all of our time doing so let's embrace
it and have the best time we can need
motivation watch a top-10 of belief
nation what's up at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out onto the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chew in today's lessons from a
man who went from being the son of a
scrap metal worker and having his
parents divorce at the age of two to
become an actor best known for playing
jacks in the FX series sons of anarchy
he's Charlie Hunnam and here's my take
on his top ten rules of success
enjoy
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one make it happen I grew up in a
very economically depressed place and I
was really struck at a young age by the
fact that everybody just was sort of in
survival modes and people weren't really
bringing forth the intention for that
life you know and then I'm got moved
when I was in my mid in my very early
teens from a place where I was quite
popular and had a robust social life to
a place where I was not popular at all
and had no social life it was very rural
area so I spent an enormous amount of
time alone when I was a child when I was
at through my teenage years which was
sort of brutal at the time but it was a
wonderful period of incubation where I
knew I wasn't happy there
so I started conceiving what I wanted my
life to be and I and I sort of retreated
into film which was my sanctuary so that
isolation and my love of film
intersected and all of a sudden like
this dream of becoming an actor rule
number two my personal favorite believe
in what you do when I think and talk
about acting I I'm much more talk
comfortable talking about it in terms of
being a craftsman that learns a trade
and and tries to improve one skillset
through a career and apply a craft to it
you know it it makes me a bit nervous
when you start to get highfalutin and
talk about art and being an artist but
at the same time one has to really
believe in the films once making like in
my heart has to be in it and I have to
just be genuinely excited the way
anybody who would love a book or loves a
movie when I'm when I'm sent a script
with a character at the center of it I
have to love that person and be so
excited creatively about being involved
and there's no part of this business
that has attracted me to try to acquire
wealth or fame I really care deeply
about storytelling and I want to tell
the stories that I feel passionate about
telling and I'd rather just stay home if
those jobs or opportunities aren't
available
to me rule number three is do something
new I felt like I've just been doing a
lot of the same thing kind of playing
like a lot of tough guys and interesting
roles but they all felt very similar and
it just kind of felt like I wanted to do
something completely different
[Music]
you know I read it and thought man I
don't know if I can change gears this
rapidly you know cuz I was kind of stuck
in Sons of Anarchy world and and
George's it was just relentless in his
pursuit of me and he wrote me a really
lovely letter and we went mad a second
time and a third time and then I just
decided you know why not rule number
four is be obsessed I really feel very
fortunate to do the job that I do I mean
my obsession has always been film and so
when I when I get a job particularly a
job as demanding and as great an
opportunity as this one was that always
becomes my obsession and while I was
shooting this it really was there's
never one second from the beginning to
the end of production
it wasn't dedicated directly to this I
mean I switched my phone off switch the
computer off and didn't have any
technology no distractions for four
months I didn't make a single phone call
I didn't send an email to anybody like
including my girlfriend I just was very
very singular in my focus that she loved
that's not a very very understanding
supportive girlfriend rule number five
create a great working environment you
know Lionel articulates this really
beautifully and is a huge advocate of
having fun at work you're on these
things for two years do you really not
want to have fun on all right this is
our lives this is what we spend all of
our time doing so let's embrace it and
have the best time we can
I Love You Man
yeah
I haven't been home at all in seven
months and one must create a family
wherever you can and that's what we did
here just to be part of guys gang to be
surrounded by good people hard-working
people and that's nice it's been nice
well formed genuinely firm friendships
would it cost a lot of Kalitta by first
and foremost become really good friends
and sort of second to that is the
creative relationship that we have you
just out in this gorgeous place and with
each other the whole time and ideas
would come up over dinner around the
campfire at night and we talked about
a/c and that's been an amazing lesson
working with guy and Lionel is that it
also seems to be that the best work
comes out the more fun you're having
rule number six work with awesome people
but you know there's there's a part of
of the editing process that I think
makes actors very very nervous because
we come in with an idea and a hope of
what we want to try to convey and imbue
and the characters that we play and try
to participate as much as possible and
then we leave the process and it gets
assembled and reimagined and it revolves
in the editing room so what I've learned
over my career is that you have to be
very careful with who you decide to work
with because you have to trust that
they're going to have good ideas in the
editing room and this was a grand
departure from what what we were doing
on set but it was very very exciting and
and I must say I I'm an enormous fan of
guys and I have been for many many many
years so I I sort of anticipated that
something exciting was gonna have
happened in the editing room so it was
it was exciting to go and actually see
what guy had come up with and and I I
was very very happy rule number seven be
an adventurer we had to we had a ferry
we got caught in a very very violent
storm and I thought that that was sort
of the point of us being there to be in
these incredibly difficult environments
and to film it and see what happened
but everybody got panicked because there
was bolts of lightning crashing around
all around us in torrential rain coming
down so they decided we need to evacuate
the set immediately because we were
about an hour Upper River from the
closest road or the club we were like in
the middle of the jungle and everybody
got very panicked and I was and pulled
violently imploring the production to
keep shooting that this is what we come
here for and then a lightning bolt had a
tree from me 25 feet from me in the
impact of it knocked me off my feet and
I fell into the river and I thought okay
maybe we should go maybe it's time to
leave at this point so we had you know
we had some experiences but to me it was
all just so exciting you know those
experiences were what this whole film
was about and why we had gone all the
way to rural Colombia to the jungle to
shoot it so you know for me every
challenge just made it feel like we were
on the right path
rule number 8 is work hard he just said
get ready and I said what is happening
who's pretty ominous and he said just
get ready and then I saw what he meant
you know he's a he's a he's got more
energy and more passion for the process
than anyone have come across in
Hollywood and he's wonderful but he is a
total slave driver you know and you know
like just for instance you know it it's
you know it's kind of like sleight of
hands in a certain way he you know he
presents these things it's gonna be
amazing man we're gonna actually build a
con party you're actually gonna do it I
said yeah that sounds fantastic cuz I
was nervous about the green screen and
the less you have to pretend the better
it's gonna be and then I got N in as I
do we know green screen list I mean it
was horrible being in I'm not really I'm
not even joking like it was horrible we
it was like being on an elliptical for
14 hours a day while wearing a suit of
armor the weighs 40 pounds
while Guillermo sprays fire at you and
250 gallons of water a minute and I was
like wow this is intense and I was in
there for 27 days so it was pretty
intense rule number nine don't
compromise I remember reading a few
years ago that you're developing a
stripper Vlad and I'm just interested in
no because it's such a cool story to
begin with if you are working on you
know developing that or is there any
other projects in the works I mean I've
been I've been trying to stay quite busy
in that regard so I have three projects
aside from Vlad that I've been
developing and I've set up at studios
that you know it's very hard to get
films made in this day and age and so
Vlad's we tried really hard I was
working with Plan B and Brad Pitt's
production company that have been
enjoying an enormous amount of success
recently but we sort of ran out of steam
on Vlad's so I'm hoping that it's a it's
an expensive film to make and my vision
of it was quite uncompromising I wanted
to tell the historically accurate
version of Vlad without in my opinion
jumping the shark and actually going
into vampirism which wasn't as
attractive or exciting for the studio
that I had sold the project to so we
found ourselves at a little bit of an
impasse and because of that the energy
sort of fizzled but I'm hoping that that
guy well at some point you know continue
hiring me and I become a big old movie
star and then I'll have the weight to
pull it out of retirement and and and
maybe maybe if a guy and I don't kill
each other by the end of the day he
could maybe have a crack at directing it
there's no more time for any more
questions Charlie and rule number 10 the
last one before the bonus clip is have
fun have you ever had an embarrassing
username I used to knock around some
chess forums as a teenager
man and my name was mantis and used to
say people used to say why's your name
mantis and I say dance with the mantis
no you slim chances which is a wu-tang
life which is I thought was quite good
at the time but sort of used a fake name
like right now in this hotel because
there's lots of you have to date people
you know try to you know can you go
everyone name the epa's before in the
past I used to go by doctor a loose
chatter have you ever used someone
else's toothbrush I am an enormous
germaphobe I wouldn't even use my
girlfriend's toothbrush that's just
fantastic
I don't know Tati I got a tattoo when I
was 18 so I had just moved to Los
Angeles I just fall in love for the
first time and it felt like there like a
real coming into page moment and I had I
kept having this dream over and over
I maybe had it a dozen times of the
tattoo that I have on my back and
exactly the position while I was having
the tattoo done at 11 o'clock in the
morning I said she said you know what we
should do we should go to Vegas and get
married
and I said that sounds like a jolly nice
idea so we drove to Vegas and got
married so that and her being my wife so
that tattoo and that being he can't
really bad idea for many reasons
now I've got a special bonus Charlie
video clip for you about fighting for
your opportunities but before that my
question the day is I want to know what
is your favorite Charlie Hunnam role and
why leave in the comments below
I'm really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
you are a good King Arthur solid choice
we're talking the guy and he said you
were not on the list initially I threw
my name in the Hat to play author and he
threw a back out and I said wait a
minute all my hopes and dreams and
imaginary friendship that I'd created
just crumbled to the ground and she said
he thought he thought you were too
skinny when I finally arrived so I got I
said screw this I'm getting on a plane
and just get me in for a cup of tea with
them and I'll convince them to let me
audition for the role of T yeah so we do
it that's how it happened yeah yeah a
cup of tea cup of tea mate yeah Wow okay
how we roll so yeah so I showed up and I
was on the last season thus guns of
Anarchy were I don't know if you know
that show there I the character like
play okay well yeah I don't assume
anything I got you so it's the character
that I played had had to enjoy this
massive trauma he'd lost his wife and
and so I wanted to lose a lot of weight
to show like the physical trauma that
he'd been through and so I showed up to
to meet with guy and we started to like
each other we started to see me I said
all right I'm in here and then with
groundswell Holly said were you just too
skinny like what what's with the
physique and he started bringing this up
time and time again I said listen it's
just for a role
I'll get thick again right and then the
final time he brought it up which was
during the audition these things are
sort of like unpleasant these like
screen tests of your room like this oh
yeah and I've been in them four or five
other actors there and all kind of like
you they all have like a different
bizarro world versus yourself it's
messed up at the beginning of it you're
just in a hallway and you're all sitting
next to each other so there's a little
bit of that going on and then when you
get to the next level which I'm sure you
know then you're in separate rooms
waiting but you're still aware of each
other and you pass each other in the
hallway so anyway he finally guy brought
up this this sort of fear about my
physicality one more time and I said
listen pal if you thought worried about
it let's just call this audition off and
you can bring those other jokers in here
and we'll fight
and whoever walks out of the room gets
the role and there was a moment where
I like you alright read the scene again
and so I think that's sort of the moment
that I that I got the role raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that mmm-hmm that people have
passion can change the way people not
one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's suppose to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details